maybe we should start talking with about
the rabbit hole problem this gentleman
who I brought a slide up of is Caleb he
posted a video here called my descent
into the alt-right pipeline he's a major
character featured in your documentary
what does Caleb's story exemplify for
you
well it actually exemplifies that we're
Beyond The Rabbit Hole um that there was
a period when the YouTube recommender
algorithm uh was aggressively uh
propagandizing viewers because you could
go on if you had a predilection to look
at you know a an influencer that had a
certain type of rhetoric that was fairly
benign you could very quickly get uh
recommended much more extreme uh
influencers and content that would that
would as the term uh illustrates would
take you down a rabbit hole it's very
difficult to get Rabbit Hole today
um they did in In fairness to YouTube do
a lot of work on that algorithm
um in fact with Caleb kind of as a test
case
um we didn't put this in the films it
was pointless but when I filmed him
which was at the Watergate Hotel because
we're we're cheeky like that
um we uh we did a a test with him where
um I had him go on his laptop and try to
Rabbit Hole himself and he couldn't the
algorithm just wasn't going to do that
and so the reason I was interested in
Caleb was Caleb you know was already on
his way to towards extremist
um views and YouTube and the influencers
they had on there at the time which were
very aggressively extreme extremists uh
like Stefan molyneux who was a big part
of the influence of the uh the shooter
and the in the Christchurch New Zealand
shooting was heavily influenced by
Stefan that got stuff on D platformed
eventually
um but it was really about where we are
post this Rabbit Hole idea the whole
idea that misinformation is so
proliferate the monetization of
propaganda is so proliferate now
um in our current culture that we're
almost all being Rabbit Hole or almost
all uh sort of in a blase way accepting
of of misinfo or flat out disinfo
um and in Caleb's case he was kind of
pulled out of that extremist Thinking by
another person on YouTube which was
Natalie Wynn uh which we use to kind of
prove a point that you know the some of
the Harms are here but a lot of the
antidote for those harms can be found in
the same place can be found in YouTube
itself
yeah at one point you actually quote
Caleb as saying I wasn't radicalized by
YouTube I was already radicalized but he
was talking about that the videos that
he was watching killed his empathy but
then he comes across Contra points uh as
she is better known and it's kind of
fascinating that you know
to to see uh YouTube is is not you know
an engine of disaster or to the extent
that it is it also becomes an agent of
empathy as well
exactly I think that that that's really
exemplifies the internet itself it's the
it's the whole spectrum of human
um experience the the issue is to focus
on the harms and what I wanted to get at
in the film was hey I wanted to put a
human face on all of these issues
because I think that's important and
that's what docs are very good at you
can read a million articles about
YouTube and about social media and see a
million documentaries that don't really
humanize a core cast of characters that
give you an emotional understanding of
the issues at play
um and so from the people who actually
experienced it not like actors or
reenactments or something so uh that was
very important to me but I also wanted
to get past this idea of the algorithm
which in in my opinion is kind of a
diversion tactic by these monopolized
tech companies to just flood you with
confusing Tech rhetoric that just makes
the average person's eyes glaze over and
then you never get into the details of
how you can maybe make these places work
better
um and yes there are algorithms and yes
there are a lot of Engineers who need to
be working on algorithms but most of us
are not Tech Engineers most of us are
including the people who run Google and
YouTube are just people with basic
incentives
um and there was these basic incentives
that I was most interested in focusing
on with this film which in this case is
their business model which is an ad
Revenue based business model which is
attached is a dollar to content that
holds you on platform and to them just
like the yellow journalists of
yesteryear
um as we all know the most salacious
type of content is normally the most
ad-friendly and that is the case with
YouTube in a way that I think is
problematic so you mentioned that now
things have changed and you even tried
to get Caleb to Rabbit Hole himself and
could not does that indicate to you that
something shifted in the the incentives
is that that the advertisers start to
get uncomfortable with the kind of press
that YouTube was getting and therefore
they decided to shift the algorithm I
mean how how did the business model work
to sort of correct itself in this case
it's the opposite
um it's the opposite of of it getting
better of there being less harmful
information of advertisers getting wary
what it what it was was that the they
don't need to Rabbit Hole you to get you
to watch salacious content this
information is now pervasive right I
mean I have friends who are on all sides
of the political aisle who flirt with
extremely bananas uh theories of either
Flat Earth or just very cockamami ideas
about about the world that are not
fact-based the sort of non-fat-based uh
culture is pervasive so you don't need
the incentives aren't there to to force
you algorithmically
um into this kind of towards this kind
of content as Joe Pulitzer knew in the
late 1800s it's just human nature right
you you are you are pre you are
pre-wired to connect more intensely with
hyperbolic angry negative content than
you are with middle of the road fact
based content so it actually they don't
need to do that it's really a human
issue it's the parasocial relationship
of having someone looking into a webcam
like I'm looking at you guys and you're
looking back at me it's that very human
non-algorithmic parasocial component
that makes YouTube so powerful yeah and
when you put it when you attach that to
content then you can monetize that yeah
when you say it's it's you know negative
or you know in hyperbolic and things
like that how does that explain you know
the emergence of somebody like Mr Beast
on YouTube who's one of the largest
um you know channels uh and characters
and it's if anything it's relentlessly
upbeat it's like Barney the dinosaur you
know post uh uh you know uh going
through uh puberty or something like
that
um is it actually is it negative like
salacious negative hyperbolic is that
the is that how they keep people
watching or is it more catering to what
people are interested in
I think it's both I think that when you
deal with with media a media platform as
big as YouTube of which there is no
larger media platform right
um you're going to be targeting
massively uh disparate demographics uh
Mr Beast uh for instance my middle
school kid loves Mr Beast and all of his
friends in Middle School of Mr Beast but
I've never watched a single Mr Beast
video in my entire life and neither have
my two older children not one not a
single one so
um you're just talking about about
demographics and I think that's where
it's a business model problem because to
to advertisers are looking at a pie
chart of numbers and they're not
differentiating at all between Mr Beast
and Stephen Crowder right but of course
there is a difference between Mr peace
and Stephen Crowder because Mr Beast is
like doing this kind of benign you know
whatever coming and earn a million
dollars by jumping off this bridge and
Stephen Crowder is calling for civil war
after the FBI goes down to Mar-A-Lago to
look at Trump's classified documents and
and to an Advertiser it's just it's just
data points it's the same to return to
the uh Contra points Natalie Wynn
example for a second because what I find
really interesting about that channel
and about what Natalie is doing there is
she's kind of embracing this landscape
that you're describing or just like this
is she's just accepting like this is the
water we're swimming in it's a very
personal medium and um she just directly
engages with the culture War arguments
dissects the dishonest rhetoric and kind
of jumps into the arena instead of
sitting on the sideline begging YouTube
to de-platform or demonetize people and
does it in a very stylized way as we can
see here this is kind of the aesthetic
established that's designed to maximize
engagement kind of do what you need to
do on YouTube to reach an audience and
reach outside of an echo chamber and
build a following and in this case
there's evidence that that approach is
an effective tactic what is your
takeaway from what's the Contra points
channel has done
takeaways and I think this is Natalie's
having spoken to her about it is that
you work with the tools you have
um so I think when you have something
that has four I mean YouTube has 4.6 or
4.7 billion video views per day
so there's a lot of people who don't
have the tools at Natalie's disposal
Natalie's working with what Natalie has
to be involved I know that Natalie that
Contra points is very
um supportive of Civic engagement and
Civic response
um so you know she has been able to
build up a massive audience on YouTube
which is extremely rare I would I would
also add
um so there it is not by any means the
only tool that people should be using
Carrie Goldberg is using the tools at
her disposal as a lawyer to literally
create lawsuits and go after
um for for very specific arms based on
very specific issues on platform
um so I think it's incumbent I mean my
general opinion is it's all hands on
deck
um I think that because and and to be
fair to Google including Google hands on
deck right um and including pictures
from within their own company
um which are basic I just think that
we've never seen in human history uh
company this is Industrial Revolution
the digital technological Industrial
Revolution that we're currently in has
moved and accelerated Pace the likes of
which we've never seen so we're all
playing catch-up a little bit hey thanks
for watching that clip from our
conversation with Alex Winter about his
new documentary the YouTube effect you
can watch another clip right here or the
full conversation right here do you have
an idea for a future guest or future
topic let us know in the comments and
please subscribe for notifications
whenever our new videos go live
our interviews go live every Thursday at
1pm see you there